when I was young I wanted to be on TV
the lights the cameras the makeup the
dimers life and from my vantage point
just outside of a military base in
Lawton Oklahoma I didn't make the
distinction between TV reporter or actor
it was all the same to me
it was either reporting live from Berlin
or I shall attend her here and woo her
with such footage when she comes it was
all special it was all the spotlight and
I just knew that it was for me but
somewhere along my journey life happened
much better I have a disease called
vitiligo it started early in my career
it's a autoimmune disorder it's where it
looks like your skin's getting white
patches but it's actually void of color
it affects all ethnicities it affects
all ages all genders it's not contagious
it's not life-threatening but it is
mental warfare it's tough now I was
diagnosed with this disease when I was
working on Eyewitness News in New York
City I was in the biggest city in the
country I was on their flagship station
and I was on their top-rated 5 p.m.
newscast and the doctor looked me right
in the eye and said you have a disease
called vitiligo it's a skin disorder
where you'll eat will you lose your
pigment there is no cure but there are
la Lala Charlie Brown's teacher he said
there is no cure all I heard was my
career is over but I just couldn't give
up I couldn't quit because we put too
much into this and by we I mean mr. Moss
who sent me to speech and drama club
instead of to detention or my sister who
paid part of my college expenses or my
mom who simply gave me everything
I would not quit so I decided to just
put on makeup and keep it moving I had
to wear makeup anyway is TV baby right I
just put on a little more makeup and
everything's cool and that actually went
very well for years I went from being a
reporter in New York City to being a
Morning Show anchor in Detroit the Motor
City and as the disease got worse I just
put on more makeup it was easy
except for my hands see this disease is
progressive and ever-changing that means
it comes and goes at one point for about
a year and a half my face was completely
white yeah it trips me out - yeah and
then with a little help some of the
pigment came back but living through
this process was like two sides of a
coin when I'm at work and I'm wearing
the makeup or wearing the makeup outside
and I'm the TV guy hey how you doing
everybody great at home without the
makeup I take it off and it was like
being a leper the stairs constantly
staring at me that the comments under
their breath some people refuse to shake
my hand some people move to the other
side of the sidewalk move to the other
side of the elevator I felt like they
were moving to the other side of life it
was tough and those were some tough
years and honestly sometimes I just had
to shelter in place you know what I mean
kind of just stay at home until I get my
mind right but then I put my blinders
back on I get back out there do my thing
but in the
process of doing that I developed this
angry grumpy demeanor anger is a easy
go-to and people would leave me alone
but it just wasn't me it wasn't me I was
allowing this disease to turn me into
this
angry grumpy spotted guy it just wasn't
me so I had to change I knew I could not
change other people people are gonna
react and do what they gonna do but
there was a cold hard reality as well I
was the one that was showing anger
sadness and isolating myself it was
actually a choice I was walking out the
door every day expecting the world to
react with negativity so I just gave
them that mean face first if I want to
change the change had to start with me
so I came up with a plan two-parter not
that deep number one I would just let
people stare drink it in stare all you
want and not react because the truth is
is when I got this disease I was all up
in the mirror staring at every new spot
trying to figure out what is going on so
I needed to let other people have that
same opportunity to get that visual
understanding number two I would react
with positivity and that was simply a
smile or at the very least a
non-judgmental kind face simple plan but
it turned out to be more difficult than
I thought but over time
start to go okay likes one time I'm at
the store and this dude is like staring
at me he's like burning a hole in the
side of my head I'm shopping he's
staring at me I'm going to the checkout
he's staring at me I'm checking out he's
on the other line checking out he's
staring at me we go to the exit he's
still staring at me so I I see he's
staring and finally I turned to him and
I go hey buddy what's up he goes up
those rocks up high awkward sure sure
so to relieve the tension I say it's
just the skin disorder it's not
contagious it's not life-threatening it
just makes me look a little different I
end up talking to that guy in the
grocery store for like five minutes it
was kind of cool right and at the end of
our conversation he says you know if you
didn't have video Largo it's actually
vitiligo but he was trying so if you
didn't have it Largo you do you'd look
just like that guy on TV good eye like
yeah I get that I get that yeah so
things were going okay I was having more
good exchanges than bad until that day
had a little time before work so I like
to stop by the park to watch the kids
play they're funny so I got a little too
close this little girl wasn't paying
attention she's about 2 or 3 years old
she's running she runs directly into my
leg and falls down pretty hard
I thought she hurt herself so I reach
out to try and you know help the little
girl
and she looks at my vitiligo and she
screams now kids are pure honesty she's
like 2 or 3 this little girl she wasn't
trying to be mean she didn't have any
malice in her heart this little girl was
afraid she was just afraid
I didn't know what to do I just took a
step back put my hands by my side I
stayed in the house for two weeks and
three days on that one it took me a
second to get my mind around the fact
that I scare small children and that was
something that I could not smile away
but I jumped back on my plan and I just
put on my blinders started going back
out two months later I'm in a grocery
store reaching on the bottom shelf and I
hear a little voice go we've got a
boo-boo it's like a two-year-old
three-year-old same age little girl but
she's not crying
so I kneeled down in front of her and I
don't speak two-year-old so I look up at
the mom I said what did she say and she
says she thinks she have a boo-boo
so I go no I don't have a boo-boo no not
at all and the little girl says does
Ahoy and so I looked to mom for the
translation and she says she thinks
you're hurt and I said no sweetie I'm
not hurt at all I'm fine and the little
girl reaches out with that little hand
and touches my face she's trying to rub
the chocolate into the vanilla or
whatever she was doing it was amazing it
was awesome because she thought she knew
what it was she was giving me everything
I wanted kindness compassion and with
the touch of that little hand she healed
a grown man's pain yee-haa healed I
smiled for a long time on that one
positivity is something worth fighting
for and the fight is not with others
it's internal if you want to make
positive changes in your life you have
to consistently be positive my blood
type is actually be positive
I know corny TV Guide dad joke my
daughter hates it but I don't care be
positive a 14 year old boy years ago
this kid had vitiligo he asked me to
show my face on television I wasn't
gonna do it we've been over this I
thought I was gonna lose my job but the
kid convinced me by saying if you show
people what you look like and explained
this to him maybe they will treat me
differently boom blinders off I did a TV
report got an overwhelming response so I
didn't know what to do I took the
attention and focused it back on the kid
and other people that have vitiligo I
started a support group pretty soon we
noticed VIP friends and be strong
support groups all over the country in
2016 we all came together and celebrated
world vitiligo day this past June 25 we
had over 300 people all in celebration
of our annual event it was amazing
now I'm not gonna lie to you and say it
was quick or easy for me to find a
positive place living with this disease
but I found it but I also got much more
I became a better man the man I always
wanted to be the kind of guy who can
stand up in front of a roomful of
strangers and tell some of the toughest
stories in his life and end it all with
a smile and find happiness in the fact
that you all just smiled back thank you
[Music]